either ancient Egyptians were far older
or far more advanced than we were ever
taught in school and I strongly suspect
that the answer is both take a look at
these photos here many of which I
utilized in a prior video about evidence
that suggests that ancient Egyptians had
some sort of lost ancient high
technology such as various stones that
many have suggested are evidence of
ancient machining or saw cutting
technology in fact many of these photos
that you're looking at here were taken
by Brien Foerster well mentioned in just
a moment now in my prior video I outline
the various tools that Egyptologists and
archaeologists have stated that the
dynastic Egyptians had such as dolerite
stone hammers as well as bronze chisels
which when you consider the most scale
of hardness and stone such as basalt
rose Granite's and quartzite which are
found throughout Egypt that there's no
possible way that those types of tools
could have cut in carved stones of this
level of hardness now in that video I
fail to address the most common rebuttal
I received which is that look no you do
not need advanced technology to cut and
carve these these stones in fact you can
utilize primitive methods such as strain
water and sand and even copper to cut
through these stones in fact there's
videos on YouTube where you can see
people do this where people can cut and
carve these stones or even individuals
that use primitive methods to move
stones that are several tons in weight
and they're able to do it all by
themselves through very simple primitive
methods however if we are to agree that
these primitive methods were utilized to
cut and carve these stones throughout
age in Egypt then that alone completely
debunked the time frame narrative as
outlined by Egyptologists archaeologists
and historians because it simply does
not compute when you consider just how
long it takes to cut and carve stones
with these primitive methods it does not
add up in fact people have even
suggested that if these are the methods
that were utilized and if we had every
single Egyptian in ancient times working
on these things 24/7 that probably still
be working on them today now I don't
know if that's true or not in fact what
I can say is that it's impossible for
anyone to actually estimate how long it
took to accomplish these various works
whether it's the cut and carved stones
utilizing the pyramids stone statues or
other structures frown throughout
ancient Egypt and the reason is because
we keep finding new stuff in fact in
just the last 2 months alone there have
been multiple discoveries in Egypt that
have made international headlines
throughout mainstream media outlets
around the world one of which was the
discovery of a massive stone statue
found underground or even more
interesting the discovery of an entirely
new pyramid that is in ruins and buried
under the desert within Egypt I mean
regardless of the debate of how pyramids
were constructed I think we can all
agree that they were certainly built to
last so what on earth happened to that
pyramid to put it into ruins how was it
destroyed I mean was it so old that it
just started falling apart I mean for
real how many hundreds of thousands if
not millions of years would it take for
that to happen and if it was destroyed
how and who or what did that when you
take a moment just to reflect on that it
raises some really interesting questions
but the point that I'm making here is
that they keep finding new evidence they
keep finding new cut stones in that when
you consider all of ancient Egypt
combined there are tens of millions of
cut stones statues and structures found
throughout that there's no possible way
that these primitive methods could have
accomplished all of these works anywhere
near the period of time as outlined in
our history textbooks what you either
suggest that ancient Egyptians and human
civilization is far older than we were
taught in school or we are more advanced
or both I mean we already have enough
evidence to conclude that ancient humans
were significantly older than we were
taught I mean take the case of the Great
Sphinx which there is such significant
water erosion around the limestone
bedrock enclosure of the Sphinx in fact
more than 200 professional geologists
from around the world have visited the
Great Sphinx and said yes this water
erosion is without a doubt the result of
tens of thousands of years of heavy rain
flow in the last times the Nile Delta
received that type of rainfall was at
least seven thousand years ago which is
nearly double the age as outlined by
historians and Egyptologists of the age
of the Great Sphinx so it doesn't add up
and it's even worth mentioning that dr.
Robert Schoch geologist from Boston
University
has told his peers that this evidence of
water erosion is so significant that it
could be a hundred thousand years old
but they need to discuss the primitive
methods of cutting these stones another
step further take for example the 100
ton stone boxes and there's nearly three
dozen of them found at the serra p.m. in
egypt they are leveled down to within
two ten thousandths of an inch which is
comparable to modern technology and we
consider not just these stone boxes but
say the stone box found at elephantine
island which has corners that are so
detailed that they could not be done in
modern times without diamond bit drills
and modern day stonemasons have visited
these sites and looked at these works
and have stated that there's no possible
way that string or copper or bronze or
sand could have machine-cut these
corners down to what we see today that
there's clearly more to the story than
what we've been told and even take into
consideration the unfinished obelisk
more than twelve hundred tons in weight
has incredible scoop marks carved out of
solid rose granite and these same scoop
marks are found on the underside of it
which completely contradicts the ability
to utilize stone dollar Wright hammers
at the angle which these scoop marks are
found that clearly well there's just
more to the story than then rose granite
being pounded away or even that string
and sand and water was used to slowly
carve it out when you look at the
concave of not just the stone carved out
of the obelisk but even other stones
found throughout ancient Egypt or even
drill holes you have to start asking
real questions which is how did they do
this and of course I must mention that
these drill holes found throughout
ancient Egypt as well as other
megalithic sites around multiple
continents around the world could have
been done with primitive methods as you
see here but it brings me to the case of
say the colossi of memnon two statues
which are 60 feet in height each which
individually are 720 tonnes which were
carved out of one solid piece of
quartzite each but how in the world
could have the primitive methods that
are suggested by Egyptologists and
others could have cut and carved
something on this scale I mean take a
look at just how small these people are
in comparison to this statue and that
doesn't even consider just what it took
to
move the colossi of memnon I mean in
modern times when the Los Angeles County
Museum of the Arts wanted to move a 340
ton stone block which is less than half
the weight of each of the individual
colossi of memnon they had to custom
build an Emmet International truck which
was nearly 300 feet long and had 196
wheels it took almost a week to move a
stone block just over a hundred miles
and the colossi of memnon are made out
of quartzite and the closest area in the
region where they could find quartzite
to the site that they're at is nearly
400 miles away so how did the ancient
Egyptians how in the world will be able
to move something so big for some reason
I really doubt that they used logs and
rollers to move it that far of a
distance for something that was so
massive and so heavy something that was
estimated to have been a thousand tons
prior to have being cut and carved to
bring this all to a close what we were
taught in school and what they're still
teaching in the textbooks today
involving ancient human civilization has
been debunked we were far older and far
more advanced than we ever thought
possible
and I have many other videos that
outline this now let me real quick
mentioned that all the photos that
you've seen in this presentation I
sourced from Google Images however I do
recognize several of them from
originating from the works of Brien
Foerster check out his youtube channel
subscribe to him like his videos because
this gentleman is going throughout the
world to various megalithic sites and
showing you first-hand evidence on
camera that things that you never seen
before including many of the photos that
you've seen here before and many many
other things and he also has a website
hidden Inca Torres calm so without a
doubt definitely go check him out
anyways guys I'll leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe leave me a comment let me
know what your thoughts are and I have
many videos to come and a whole wide
variety of topics take care everybody